[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 60,18 l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en 26 minutes tout de suite les
titres de ce jeudi 3 octobre la
mobilisation des enseignants aujourd'hui
plusieurs se sont rassemblés dans le
département et notamment à trappes
action qui fait suite au suicide d'une
directrice d'école en seine saint denis
fin septembre et dénoncé dans une lettre
ses mauvaises conditions de travail
l'inauguration d'une résidence sociale
elancourt les pré accueil 190 logements
pour des travailleurs qui connaissent
des difficultés économiques elles locaux
on remplace l'ancien foyer construit sur
place dans les années soixante dix enfin
le dernier volet de notre dossier sur le
cinéma le territoire des yvelines qui
est regorge de talents du septième art
certains ont explosé aux yeux de la
france et du monde d'autres plus jeunes
rêves de grandeur zoom dans cette
édition et on parlera tout à l'heure de
l'automne des créateurs à versailles un
marché va s'installer ce week-end dans
la cité royale à des rassemblements
organisés dans tout les yvelines en
hommage à christiane renonce cette
directrice d'école du 93 qui s'est donné
la mort fin septembre et dont les
obsèques étaient aujourd'hui raison
invoquée pour son suicide et les
conditions de travail
attrape devant l'école élémentaire henri
wallon une centaine d'enseignants
étaient mobilisés à la mi journée ils
ont lu la dernière lettre écrite par la
directrice avant son geste
une minute de silence a été également
observées on écoute les réactions au
micro de michael et demi d'euros la
situation de crise et leur nom
témoigne effectivement de 7 ses
difficultés des collègues dans leurs
conditions de travail et des conditions
de travail dégradées et on a
l'impression que quelquefois de la
ministre à sion fait ne prend pas en
compte tous les directeurs de trappes
ont ce sentiment en lisant sa lettre on
a tous eu l'impression qu'elle décrivait
ce qu'on vivait et ben tout peut
basculer du jour au lendemain quand on
est un peu moins forte les autres
mobilisations rassemblé 150 personnes à
plaisir aux mureaux et à mantes-la-ville
les enseignants qui ont été reçus en
délégation intersyndicale par le
directeur académique des yvelines ils
ont pu exprimer au cours de la rencontre
les difficultés quotidiennes rencontrées
par leurs collègues directeurs d'école
autre mobilisation qui se profile
dimanche sur un autre sujet celle des
antilles pma laurence rochât conseillère
à départementale des yvelines et
présidente de sens commun sera avec nous
tout à l'heure par téléphone pour parler
du sujet elle a été inaugurée en début
de semaine à elancourt la résidence
sociale les prix remplace l'ancien foyer
de travailleurs migrants construit dans
les années 70 dans la ville et logement
sont désormais plus moderne et plus
fonctionnel les détails de rayon voici à
quoi ressemble il ya trois ans l'ancien
foyer de travailleurs migrants au petit
prêt à elancourt aujourd'hui composé de
190 logements cette résidence sociale
accueille des travailleurs qui
connaissent des difficultés économiques
c'est adoma sociétés oeuvrant pour
l'insertion par le logement qui a dirigé
les travaux de transformation durant 24
mois
les ftm c'était des unités de vie où on
trouvait des batteries de wc des
batteries de douches et des unités de
cuisine et avec des toutes petites
chambres des chambres de 7 mètres carrés
50 aujourd'hui ses 190 logements ou le
confort de tout à chacun et se retrouve
dans ce logement et on a des ce qu'on
nomme des logements autonomes
cette résidence est ouverte à tous les
habitants ils restent généralement pour
une courte durée deux ou trois ans coût
du projet plus de 12 millions d'euros
il a été subventionné notamment par
l'état l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines ou encore la ville
d'elancourt
on doit montrer
à tous les élans cortois qu' on est
toujours très à l écoute du social mais
de le marier avec la qualité et c'est
pas facile dans un contexte comme
mondiale difficile avec tout le problème
de l'explosion bien sûr démographique
que tous les pays doivent doivent gérer
ici en tout cas c'est un modèle
qualitatif dont on est fier dans le
cadre de la rénovation de ce quartier
des aménagements ont également été
réalisés aux abords de la résidence dans
le reste de l'actualité la 42e opération
coup de pouce pour un emploi ce job
dating se dérouler aujourd'hui à au
centre flora tristan à plaisir organisé
par l'association rencontres pour
l'égalité d'accès à l'emploi
une centaine de jeunes présents pour
rencontrer des entreprises qui recrutent
dans le département dans des secteurs
très variés
elle est candidat avec quelques minutes
en tête à tête avec un potentiel
employeur pour peut-être à la fin de
l'entretien décrocher une alternance un
cdd ou un cdi matile de 2 min pour les
interviews collecter évidemment faut que
ça aille vite c'est un job dating
donc il faut se présenter très vite avec
le sourire et présenter les points
positifs de son expérience
une fois de plus il ya une confiance en
soi à acquérir et c'est sûr là dessus
surtout que nous nous travaillons donner
aux jeunes la confiance qu'ils soient
qu'ils sont en forme et à-propos
d'emploi les yvelines compte 3000
entreprises du bâtiment pour qu'elles
soient au fait des dernières actualités
dernières technologies du secteur est la
fédération française du bâtiment
organisait ce jeudi son deuxième salon
70 conférences de la maison connectée
aux nouvelles technologies automobiles
et des démonstrations avec par exemple
un drone qui nettoie la toiture pour
aider les couvreurs l'événement s'est
tenu toute l'après-midi à la firme du
manet à montigny le bretonneux propos
recueillis par marie ligne à pishin
c'est salon du bâtiment la tête du tech
data deuxième édition pointe a fait une
année dernière on a fait une semaine
qu'on art modifié
demande de nos exposants et de nouveaux
artisans c'est pour afficher tous les
produits nouveaux la maison connectée
ce qui est par trop mais c'est d'abord
pour nos artisans et on veut que tout le
monde y participe dès qu'ils s'en
fassent une production et qui retrouve
notre adn du bâtiment le lieu est ouvert
depuis à cette année près de la gare de
saint rémy les chevreuse l'aiguillage
cette maison du tourisme et de l
écomobilité propose des locations de
vélos et de véhicules électriques pour
circuler en vallée de chevreuse one
health until l'aiguillage ce nom vous
dit il quelque chose
l'ancienne maison du garde barrière de
la ligne paris chartres a fait peau
neuve pour devenir en mars dernier la
maison du tourisme et de la mobilité
elle est située stratégiquement juste à
côté de la gare de saint rémy les
chevreuse et a pour but de promouvoir
l'activité touristique du parc géré par
la société et cox dans le cadre du pôle
éco mobilité de la vallée de chevreuse
elle offre différents services pour les
particuliers et pour les entreprises
alors il ya deux activités dans cette
maison il ya l'office du patrimoine qui
est au dessus à laitages nous qui est
vraiment là pour aiguiller tous les
touristes qui sont là pour vraiment
découvrir le parc c'est vraiment un but
touristique
et nous qui sommes aussi là pour
développer l'activité qu'on appelle
écomobilité donc entre autres le
tourisme à vélo dans dans le parc
location et vente de vélos 90 places de
stationnement pour vélos location de
véhicules électriques
la société cherche à attirer le plus
grand nombre d'adhérents
pour cela elle mise sur une autre
facette la réparation de vélos mon qui
propose deux grandes familles de vélos
qui sont les vélos à assistance
électrique et les vélos classiques qu'on
peut aussi appeler vélo musculaire en
danse et v dans ces deux grandes
familles on propose des vélos urbains
vraiment des vélos deal qu'on peut
appeler aussi des vélos de femmes en col
de cygne donc vraiment adapté pourra
rouler sur la route et piste cyclable
typiquement quelqu'un qui s'en sert pour
aller au marché enfin voilà dix
déplacements urbains on a des vtc donc
ça c'est des vélos un peu plus
polyvalents qui peuvent tout aussi bien
rouler sur la route piste cyclable et
donc sur les petits chemins de terre
c'est ça passe quand même relativement
partout et on a les vtt donc là par
contre c'est vraiment adapté à une
pratique un peu plus sportives ou en
tout cas qui passe beaucoup mieux
à ça on rajoute
une proposition de sièges enfants de
petite remorque pour les enfants et puis
bientôt aussi des vélos pour enfants
l'aiguillage de saint rémy les chevreuse
vient s'ajouter à une dizaine d'autres
magasins répartis sur toute la france et
devient ainsi une nouvelle solution pour
vos déplacements en vallée de chevreuse
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure les
antilles à pma pour toutes les femmes se
rassemblent dimanche 21 associations
vont défiler à paris sous la bannière
marche aux enfants bon sur leurs seules
trochut avec nous par téléphone
présidente de sens commun conseillère
départementale des yvelines est aussi
élue municipale d'opposition à
guyancourt
vous avez signé fin septembre une
tribune dans le figaro pour le rejet de
la loi bioéthique et dont l'article 1
relative justement à la pma pour toutes
a été adoptée en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
pourquoi cette mobilisation dimanche que
souhaitez vous dénoncez alors nous
d'abord par cette loi comme vous l'avez
dit elle à elle comporte en l'article
sur la paiement mais elle va bien au
delà on fait quoi on parle a pris de
faciliter la recherche sur les cellules
souches embryonnaires pour justement
envie d'agréer peut-être qu'il a trois
par an
des mélanges de trélut animale et
humaine
vous voyez en fait dans fait dans ce
projet de loi qui en est avec nous il
n'ya plus de lits éthiques
il ya plus de lui en fait tout d'un coup
d'accusations de qui fait aujourd'hui
l'humanité et du coup un dévoiement du
rôle de la médecine la médecine n'est
plus là pour réparer les corps l élan
finalement pour les transformer et tu
qu'on veut vraiment aller c'est alors
l'article aux le disais tout à l'heure
relatif à l'élargissement de la pma pour
toutes les femmes a été adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale le texte entier un
la loi bioéthique est encore en
discussion est ce que du coup cette
mobilisation elle arrive pas déjà trop
tard
c'est dimanche cette mobilisation le
projet de loi comme olivier
[Musique]
donc ce qui va compter c'est l'adoption
du définitif de ce projet de loi
ce projet de loi il va ensuite allé au
sénat il va être examiné par les
sénateurs avant de revenir à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'axé par prothétique les
sept lots et aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
ya des associations qui sont réunis en
collectif qui travaillent bien sûr mais
le travail premier est celui des
parlementaires et on a vu à quel point
il avait plu en connexion soulever un
pas de questions qui avait été balayé
d'un revers de main aucun amendement n'a
été n'a été acceptée par la majorité la
république en marche et ils font
traitement même en amendement comment
dire des mères porteuses
alors que le mariage pour tous
l'adoption du match pour tous il ya
quelques années la manif pour tous avait
revendiqué 1,4 million de manifestants
dimanche seulement deux cent mille
manifestants sont attendus à paris y'a
pas une crainte que ce combat mobilise
moins que pour le mariage pour tous à
tournoi est en tout cas au niveau des
parlementaires parfois là on va vraiment
à l'enfant l'aveyron on a le sentiment
d'être effectivement d'en voir
l'engrenage puisque au moment du mariage
pour qui vous voulez mais non bien sûr y
aura pas d'effets la fema aujourd'hui au
fond de la baignoire est en vie mais non
bien sûr y aura pas la gpa est en fait
pourquoi il n'y aurait pas de
mobilisation au programme ce dimanche
merci laurence rochât avec nous par
téléphone conseillère départementale d
asie vinh élue municipale d'opposition à
vue en cours également la présidente de
sens commun est la fin de notre dossier
du mois consacré au cinéma dans les
yvelines le département vivier de
talents du septième art nombreux sont
ceux qui connaissent aujourd'hui la
gloire des festivals et récompenses mais
de jeunes talents reste aussi deux
grandeurs reportage avec la
collaboration de michael et demi d'euros
les yvelines terre de cinéma terre de
talents du septième art aussi isabelle
huppert jacques tati guillaume canet
bérénice bejo ou encore l'oscarisé jean
dujardin
tous sont nés sont passés où ont vécu
dans le département la liste de ses
acteurs et réalisateurs est très longue
et non exhaustive et malgré une carrière
remplie certains n'oublient pas leurs
racines que ce soit le trappistes omar
sy pour la présentation d'un film à
saint quentin où le réalisateur eric
toledano intervenant dans son ancien
collège à versailles
il leur arrive parfois de revenir sur
leur territoire passage au musée passage
porte bonheur de venir à skywest c'est
le cinéma où je vous je venais quand je
sécher les cours
il ya mon lycée qui est juste devant
donc c'est une forme de pèlerinage quoi
j'ai grandi à versailles et alors si on
est constitué de la ville d'où revient
les expériences à l'inter de cette ville
le collège c'est quand même une période
très structurante dans la vie
poutine bien nouveaux collègues pour toi
ma soi disant enfermés pour atteinte à
l'intégrité physique d'un groupe de
personne alors qu'en fait c'est juste
une agression à la grenade
lui aussi est originaire de versailles
et à la cote en ce moment alban ivanov
fait cette année à la fiche d'une
dizaine de films à l'instar de jamel
debbouze et 2 mars si sa carrière a
débuté dans l'humour avant de se
poursuivre sur grand écran
moi j'ai voulu commencer acteurs mais ça
ça marchait pas il faudrait pas à
l'époque et c'est ce qui fait que je me
suis dirigé vers la scène et le one man
show d'accord parce que j'en avais marre
d'attendre qu'on m'appelle pour le
cinéma c'est ça et c'est en fait c'est
une fois que j'ai fait le deuil du
cinéma et je me suis vraiment mis à fond
dans la seine le cinéma commence à
s'intéresser à vous mais dans les
yvelines aussi de jeunes talents depuis
plusieurs années le réalisateur quentin
du puits seront au festival de cannes
pour vendre ses productions
à 29 ans le plaisir ou a déjà une
quinzaine de réalisations à son actif
raconter des histoires c'est ce qui a
poussé ce fan de george lucas c'est
ridley scott à faire du cinéma
faire un film c'est très long soit un
court métrage d'une publicité ou
évidemment un long métrage mais tout
prend du temps et il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont difficiles où on peut
douter comme dans beaucoup de métiers
donc il faut avoir cette passion-là pour
réussir à traverser joie qui sont
difficiles on voit pas forcément
l'objectif ont pas forcément le film
fini on va pas forcément le projet fini
essayons donc au bout du chemin il y a
le film il ya l'histoire qu'on veut
raconter qu'on veut montrer aux gens
après avoir tourné une publicité au
château de grousset cet été quand un
dupuis s'attelle à un autre projet la
réalisation d'un documentaire sur yacine
haddad un boxeur de sa salle de sport à
maurepas sept ans viennent de montrer
l'envers du décor de montrer ce que
c'est qu'aujourd'hui quatre
professionnels de la boxe en france est
de montrer malgré le fait que yacine
soient professionnels tous les
sacrifices que ça représente de devoir
travailler à côté d'eux
quelle honte en prime celle qui ne peut
pas vivre aujourd'hui de ton sport par
exemple l'avenir du réalisateur est fait
de longs métrages trois sont en projet
pour rêver pourquoi pas d'être un jour
reconnu par ses pairs
à versailles les créateurs vont être à
l'honneur ce samedi la révolution du
fait-main organise
la troisième édition du marché des
créations fait main et made in france et
pour en parler les deux organisatrices
cendres coelho et solène caceres
montfort mesdames vous êtes donc les
créatrices de cette société à la
révolution du fait main qui organise cet
événement pourquoi justement consacré un
marché aux créations du fait main et
aussi aux créations made in france
alors du coup pardon parce que du coup
on aime da beaucoup le tout ce qui est
made in france ou des créations locales
et on aime aussi va pouvoir mettre en
place et tous ceux de cette organisation
et avoir un ensemble en fait de
créateurs tous ensemble on fait un
partage c'est quelque chose que vous
faites au quotidien aussi au sein de la
révolution du fait-main justement
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à créer cette
entreprise à mettre en avant justement
ces créations fait main à la base
données ne deux créatrices et le but
c'était vraiment de développer le savoir
faire français et made in france
pourquoi il faut le mettre en avant ce
made in france parce que on a on est de
plus en plus des créateurs et on a
besoin de faire vivre nos entreprises
vous l'avez créé quand cette société dès
2015 2015 est donc là on en est au
troisième marché c'est un rendez-vous
qui rencontre du qui rencontre un succès
à chaque fois tout à fait là de plus en
plus les versaillais aime beaucoup en
fait c'est vraiment un point de
rendez-vous aussi pour pouvoir les
créateurs et sur le marché n'a trouvé au
marché notre dame qui a un lieu une
force et le marché des tic de versailles
sa satire du monde attire du monde et
puis a du coup ça montre aussi à un
autre type de marchés puisqu'il ya le
marché normales d'habitude et là c'est
vrai qu'avec des petits créateurs des
pièces uniques ou des petites séries et
c'est ça qu'on veut montrer c'est
vraiment le top a aidé les petits
créateurs français d'en bas qui font
différentes formes quelque chose chacun
de leur côté et on va vraiment les
réunir est-ce que ça se perd se fait
main est ce que c'est pour ça aussi vous
souhaitez le mettre en avant en parler
est ce que c'est des choses qu'on a
tendance à oublier ses créations fait
main par contre on est un peu cachée par
la masse
d'austrian donc le but c'est vraiment de
révolutionner
les créations est made in france est de
dire aussi sur lequel on est sur du
qualitatif n'ont pas forcément sur le
quantitatif mais sur des choses de
qualité
il perd important justement de tichey
précédent du de l'unique du qualitatif
et c'est pas forcément si je faire que
ça qu'on pourrait le penser en fait mais
il ya aussi un partage avec des
créateurs où les clients peuvent venir
directement par parler avec le créateur
voire commencer faire comment pour qui
sait également il y aura combien le
créateur présent pour ce marché samedi
entre 70 à 80 créateurs très bien et
vous êtes venus alors avec quelques
créations parlez nous en est ce que
c'est des créations qui seront proposés
samedi peut-être vos créations cassis
alors la petite couverture pour les
bébés donc du coup
nous avons des paniers nous avons
d'autres choses bijoux je te laisse
parler son âge et moi ce que je fais
avec des bijoux des objets de décoration
pour les enfants il fera samedi
également des de la céramique des
terrariums du cosmétique car avant
toutes sortes en fait différents univers
de création on peut représenter en fait
non c'est de montrer que l'artisanat le
fait mince et c'est très très vaste très
large et made in france avec 7
c'est aussi cette qualité
donc du coup cessé de keller à quelle
heure ce marché à versailles dès 10h
pardon à 18h30
donc samedi 5 octobre il y aura
également des ateliers
quand on organise également des ateliers
ça permet aussi de pouvoir faire soi
même bain des du cosmétique par exemple
il va ya voir ça ça permet aussi de voir
comment on peut faire une création par
soi-même et gagner ça demande beaucoup
de préparation là on en est à la
troisième édition pour faire venir les
différents créateurs où ils viennent
facilement c'est facile de les faire
venir sur ce marché du coup on est la
révolution du système depuis un certain
temps donc on connaît déjà différent on
a déjà un univers alliant vous appuyez
sur votre expérience justement est donc
plus on partait mieux c'est et de plus
en plus on a deux créateurs et et de
clients aussi
du coup on essaie de montrer ça à
versailles mais on a également une
boutique au vésinet qui permet aussi de
de venir voir des créations par exemple
si on peut pas forcément à venir à
versailles ce jour là on peut également
venir à notre boutique de créateurs et
quels sont les objectifs pour samedi du
coup qu'est ce qu'ils feraient que cette
troisième édition soit une réussite
alors la première a été vraiment un
succès la 12e également et celle-ci en
fait nous imaginons que ça va être
vraiment un réel succès parce que le
conseiller il aime bien le minime france
ils sont toujours au rendez-vous quand
c'est des événements pour les créateurs
un mot justement pour les visiteurs qui
voudraient venir pour les attirer une
sortie en famille ils peuvent se nourrir
sur place à nous avons un fou de troc
également donc non plus il va faire beau
ce serait vraiment un réel plaisir un
moment de partage de la diversité
surtout montrer la diversité
ils peuvent vraiment trouver des choses
qui leur plaisent en fête pour noël
merci merci
sandra coelho je rappelle vous êtes les
organise les organisatrices de ce marché
des créations du fait main et made in
france qui se déroule ce samedi à
versailles c'est au marché à notre dame
elle nous a rejoints pour son coup de
coeur loisirs mélanie poker bonsoir au
sein de la rédaction de tv 60,18 la
ryder cup c'était il ya tout juste un an
à saint quentin en yvelines mais
l'agglomération n'a pas dit au revoir au
golf pour autant dans quelques jours
c'est l'open de france qui débute et ce
week-end les curieux vont pouvoir s'y
essayer au golf et oui samedi à 5
octobre ce sera la 7e édition de
l'événement
ça se déroule ça se déroule au golf blue
green sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines avant d'en découvrir
un peu plus un mot de bernard des bancs
vice président aux sports
je crois que la ryder cup a fait
connaître largement le golfe mais
aujourd'hui il faut montrer que c'est le
golf est accessible à tout le monde et
c'est le but en fait de cette
manifestation c'est de faire découvrir
le golf de façon ludique et pour tous de
façon gratuite alors les premiers potes
seront donnés à 14 heures avec les
ateliers d'initiation qui sont encadrés
par les golfeurs de l'asm golf ça c'est
plutôt pour les débutants on va dire
pour ceux qui pratiquent déjà
nitties golf proposera des analyses et
des tests et vous pourrez même faire
durer la soirée puisque à partir de 20
heures et jusqu'à minuit le parcours va
se faire en nocturne practice sera
éclairé et ambiancé par un dj et entre
700 et 1000 personnes sont attendues sur
cette journée merci mélanie pour ceux
qui voudraient relever quelques
challenge des concours sont organisés et
dès 16h30 notamment un concours de
précision
c'est ça on retrouve plusieurs idées de
sortie dans quelques instants après ce
journal votre émission le 7-8 loisirs
voilà pour faire le point sur les
principales idées de sorties à faire
dans l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et aussi dans le département
merci mélanie pour terminer plus qu'un
mois avant l'ouverture au public de cet
événement la deuxième édition du
festival touahri lumière sauvage débute
le 27 octobre les visiteurs pourront
découvrir sur place
un nouveau parcours avec plus de 600
lantern plus de précision avec ce sujet
est de manon varaldo et rodolphe blondel
les petites mains s'affairent pour
préparer près de 600 lantern réalisé
entièrement à la main et recouvertes de
tissu à la tombée de la nuit elle
s'illumine avec et cinq mille ampoules
led
les pièces sont fabriquées en asie gang
en chine où règne la tradition des
festival des lanternes
j'étais allé deux fois à zhigang anti
tuân en mai juillet pour discuter le
désert du festival les aspects
techniques du projet et comment
comment réaliser toute la partie
logistique du festival les pièces ont
été transportés dans dix-huit conteneur
avant d'arriver au zoo après être
déballé les pièces sont installés les
visiteurs découvriront près 2 600
lantern plantes et animaux lumineux pour
finir au château une grande scène
renaissance en présence du roi henri iv
est au programme avec des personnages
inédits
on a un petit garçon qui fait partie du
sel renaissance sur le partage du
château avec son petit bras kate et son
balcon pour cette deuxième édition du
festival touahri lumière sauvage c'est
un nouveau parcours sur près de 3
hectares avec pour thématique la grande
odyssée de l'évolution quarante deux
scènes sont à voir comme celle ci s'est
débattu
de l'époque fin xvième siècle et sada ça
explique la raconte pas l'histoire de la
découverte du monde par la parlure
europe autour de cette époque le
festival touahri lumière sauvage est à
découvrir du 27 octobre au 8 mars 2020
la première édition avait rassemblé près
de cent cinquante mille personnes
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi demain vendredi place aux
7,8 l'hebdo marylène heye à pishin haut
et sont invités reviendront sur ce qui a
fait l'essentiel de l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines quant à moi je
vous retrouve dès lundi pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]